hello everyone and welcome to the final
game of the first day of the uh ftx
crypto cup knockouts it's magnus carlsen
versus hikaru nakamura
yeah this is game four everyone started
by winning uh
with with the white pieces first hikaru
one with white in game one then magnus
one would white in game two and then
he carl won again with white in game
three and now magnus if he doesn't wanna
go
uh well being down a point uh in the
second day of the
uh of the clash uh he has to win this
game otherwise
uh well he's just going to be down down
tomorrow uh so that being said let's
check it out and see if if
this was at all possible magnus has the
white pieces and he opens uh with e4
yet again with e5 by hikaru knight to f3
knights to c6 and again magnus goes for
bishop to c4
we have bishop to c5 and now magnus
again
castles very very risky stuff uh not
going for the
evan's game but when you need a win uh
knight to f6
and now d3 we have castles by hikaru
and now h3 uh always a useful move
when when playing the italian we have d5
attacking in the center
captures captures and now comes a4 so
this
position is not a new one uh magnus
already played against uh against sergey
karakin in the grand chester rapid
uh in paris in 2017 the game ended in a
draw
uh and the karakin went for f6 here but
here
we have bishop the e6 by hikaru and now
it is already as of move eight that we
have a completely new game
so let's see how magnus uh deals with
this he starts with knights the g5
puts pressure on this bishop and of
course hikaru not interested in
giving up bishop for a knight please
bishop to f5 then
the bishop will be very useful here as
it regards the
the h7 square you can put it to g6 so
it's
going to be a very nice defender uh we
have queen to f3 now with an attack on
the bishop and a double attack on the
knight and he carriages defense with
knights to e7
getting the snack out of the way and
defending the bishop on f5 we have c3
now preparing to advance the pawns on
the queen side and
h6 pushing the knight back knight to e4
and here that should be back to d6 so
just keeping everything uh
everything closed uh we have b4 by
magnus a few moves late but
what are you going to do and now a6 we
have knight b to d2
continuing development and now hikaru
doesn't like this bishop
on this diagonal so king to h8 so he can
uh maybe play bishop back
then f5 e4 f4 and who knows what might
happen
so here bishop to a3 by magnus and now
bishop to g6 as planned we have knight
captures on d6
uh c captures and now magnus strikes
with
with b5 and the problem is you don't
really have a good square for this
knight
if you go back then we just pick up the
b7 pawn so uh moving the knight not
really an option
uh you might move it to the a5 which is
what he car did uh but
uh yes now it defends the b7 pawn but
the knight is on a very ugly square
uh and here just bishop to b4 now
putting pressure
on this well on this knight and while
you could capture on c4 then we play
knight captures on c4 and then there's a
double attack on this uh
well d6 pawn and there's no good way to
defend it if you play something like d5
then comes knight captures an e5 and
other than that there's really there's
really no good move here if you play
something like knight to f5 then again
you
lose the b7 pawn so whatever you play
you lose something
so instead hikar went for this captures
now the rook defends the knight we have
captures here now there's a double
attack on the knight
uh and the b6 this is how hikaru
preserves preserves material
uh bishop to d5 now attacking the rook
here
and magnus not interested in capturing
uh if if you capture for example knight
captures on d5 we're gonna play queen
captures
and it doesn't get uh any better for
black uh the
the pressure is still uh very strong
here so instead after bishop to d5 we
have rook to c8 by hikaru
uh and now comes c4 just cementing that
uh
uh bishop on d5 also the b5 phone is now
reinforced
uh and hikaru now continues with his
plan which started
when he played king to h8 and that is f5
we have bishop to e6 now chasing this
rogue back and the rook to b8 by hikaru
you could bring it all the way to a8 but
the rook came from a8 and doesn't really
do all that much here we can just play
d4 and if captures then a queen f4 and
again
we put immense pressure to this d6 pawn
and that's going to be a huge problem
for black
so instead after bishop to e6 we have
rook to b8 and
now comes bishop captures on the a5 uh b
captures and now d4 so here magnus is
ready to start uh advancing those pawns
create a pawn storm and uh well
try try and win the game he needs a win
like we said to get back into the match
and now the thing is uh here e4 is a
very interesting move
problem is after queen to c3 there's a
double attack on the a5 pawn and also
you're just preparing to push
uh push a lot of pawns here okay you can
never push c5 because then the b5 hangs
but it would be it would be maybe
problematic maybe we can play d5
try and weaken the the b5 pawn then
we're going to capture here
and then something like f4 so if hikaru
wants to go really wild
he could go for something like this here
with this e4 idea but he tries to keep
everything solid he plays rook to f6
he is leading the match so uh no reason
to take any unnecessary risks but now
magnus plays
d5 we have bishop to f7 now
attacking this very strong piece bishop
captures rook captures and now
knight to b3 with a double attack on the
pawn here
so rook the a8 defending it and here uh
magnus
uh played c5 and this is a very very
strong move uh the situation on the
clock is five minutes for magnus in some
seven minutes for hikaru
uh and you need to uh you need to figure
out how to
go about this instead of this c5 you
could also try something like
just uh playing rook a2 then bringing
the other rook to a1 try and put
additional pressure to this pawn
but carlsen's idea is also a very
interesting one because hikaru here
plays
okay the point is if you capture here
then just d6 is strong
the knight is under attack you cannot
capture the rook on a8 is hanging
and once you move the knight for example
here you're going to play knight
captures on c5
and now these pawns are just incredibly
strong
it's very unlikely that black will be
able to survive this so instead after
this
c5 move we have a for by hikaru now just
attacking this knight on b3 but this
doesn't work and here
magnus plays a most interesting idea and
here
magnus plays c6 so he offers a knight
here but grabbing the knight
doesn't really do anything because you
just capture uh here
on a8 queen captures and then queen
captures on b3
and now magnus wants to well just start
advancing those pawns and it doesn't
matter he's down a piece at some point
he car will have to
give the knight back and magnus will
retain a better position
so instead after this c6 move we have
queen to b6 by hikaru but now comes
queen to d3 he defends the b5 pawn
uh we rook to b8 now attacking the pawn
but again this doesn't work and why
doesn't it work uh well uh feel free to
pause the video here and try to find
the winning move for magnus well i give
you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on finding the
only idea that wins and it's
the most basic one uh it is of course
capturing the pawn on a4
rook capture sunday four so
congratulations to everyone who found it
the point is uh
queen captures and b5 is impossible this
is what hikaru missed
uh problem is if this is uh played then
c7
wins the game now you if you capture the
queen then we capture this
with uh with check so the you don't
really gain anything and if you
well best that you have is actually just
capturing
on b3 and then we don't even capture uh
we play rook to a8 and we still win
queen captures on d3 we're just gonna
capture this with check bring another
queen into the game
uh we're still up the exchange and our
position is
very much winning so this is uh in the
position
and the hikaru saw that of course he
cannot capture the
b5 pawn he plays knight the g6 and now
comes rook to b4 now magnus just defends
his pawn
and now uh he can play well he can play
pretty much anything
knight's the f4 here by hikaru trying to
create some problems here but magnus
doesn't even
react to this he was he was interested
in giving up a piece
uh for all of these pawns uh so why not
just give up the exchange as well so
rook captures on f4 was played
e captures on f4 and now knight to d4
now we've removed the defender of the d4
squared the knight now has an outpost
here
b5 pawn is sufficiently defended and now
it's only time
uh to bring the last rook into the game
so here f3 by hikaru but magnus just
ignores him he says
while that's a very impressive pawn push
you don't really have any pieces
to be used for the attack so here rook
to c1
and now rook to a7 trying to
create some sort of a rook lift or
something but just knight to e6 and now
what do you play here
problem is if you go now after this b5
pawn then we can
simply capture the queen rook captures
and go for c7 and that's it
there's no defending this uh if you go
rook to a8 of course we will just uh
promote this captures capture so with
check and after king h7
even rook c7 is here winning this spawn
so there's really no counter play from
black here
so instead after knight to e6 we have
rooked the a2 by hikaru
now with the thread of queen captures
king to h1 and queen capture
and g2 checkmate but magnus of course
prevents this and here he just plays you
could capture on f3 but magnus just
plays queen to d4
and he was in this position i know 37
that hikaru resigned the game
as there is no point in continuing this
because well
uh if you if you move the queen
somewhere weird weird you're getting
checkmated
and uh if you don't uh you're just in a
in a terrible position
you don't really even have a square for
the queen there's
nowhere you can play the queen so best
you have is just a trade
but after this uh i mean the the pawns
are simply too strong the knight again
defends this
this guy here and it doesn't matter if
you play something like rook day four
just c7 this is winning and now after
the rook blocks we can
play whatever uh maybe we can even give
up the knight we can play b6
and then if the knight is captured in b7
and that's it there there's no playing
this rook captures
b8 queen and that's it uh we just
we just win the game very very
impressively
so after going to d4 hikar resigned and
magnus
equalizes the match the match is now 2-2
both of them won all of their games with
the white pieces and lost all of their
games with the black pieces so
very very uh interesting stuff maybe
maybe tomorrow will be different we'll
we'll see how it goes
uh but yeah uh great uh games by all
both of them
it seems like white is uh really
improving because at uh
at some point like maybe last year
everyone was playing super impressively
with the black pieces but now
it seems that uh with the with the
uh neural nets and the engines getting
stronger and stronger
the white pieces are you know again uh
producing some brilliant miniatures uh
but yeah we'll see what happens tomorrow
uh so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it uh i would like to thank
dane scott vladolaro uh devon aronson uh
robert fulham and
jacob wolf for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and
i will see you soon continuing the
coverage of this very nice event
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions
and whatever else happens uh in the
chess world so thank you all i will see
you soon and have an excellent rest of
your day